All right, we've been waiting for this.
We now have three new polls after last week's
Democratic primary debates.
And it turns out that my analysis of who did
well has translated directly into polling
changes.
And I want to go over those with you today.
The, the big picture is Joe Biden is down.
Uh, Bernie sent Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
are basically even Warren up slightly.
Uh, Kahmilah Harris got the biggest boost
while basically all of the Zeros and ones
that people polling zero and one or even up
to 2% are basically unchanged.
And some of them probably should start getting
out of the race soon.
And we'll talk about that in a little bit.
So to remind you, my analysis was that on
the first night Elizabeth Warren won.
She was the strongest on policy.
She didn't win in dramatic fashion.
She didn't have any of those big Gotcha type
moments that unfortunately, uh, in the modern
political environment are considered signs
of, of strength as a politician.
Um, I also thought that from night one who
Leon and build the Blasio did well, but they
didn't have a chance and they continue not
to have a chance.
On night two, uh, Camilla Harris was clearly
the winner in the way that a mildly involved
democratic voter would see it.
Very strong and commanding p booted judge
sort of in a quiet second place.
Bernie Sanders may be right there with them,
maybe in third place.
Bernie likely not doing damage but not really
making any big gains was my impression.
And the poll results basically have confirmed
that that's the way that on average a democratic
voters understood the debates.
So looking at the averages of the three recent
polls, rather than at any one poll, a Joe
Biden's polling continues to trickle down.
That's the Green Line at the top for people
who are watching Bernie's polling is basically
even the slightest uptick.
About half of one point, um, Elizabeth Warren
continuing this slow and steady climb that
goes all the way back to early April.
And then the biggest jump very clearly is
that orange line on the chart.
Kahmilah Harris Harris gained more than three
full points.
She's now within striking distance of Elizabeth
Warren for third place, who herself is now
within striking distance of Bernie Sanders
for second place.
And if Joe Biden doesn't turn this trend around,
Joe Biden actually risks falling out of first
place, uh, before he knows it.
You will also notice that the Zeros and ones,
as I call them, the people basically polling
nothing, have not really moved.
Uh, none of those lower down in the polling
have moved the needle.
A Marianne Williamson was polling almost a,
a has been polling almost literally zero.
She's now at 0.2%.
That may even be a drop from before the debate.
I don't remember.
Jay Inslee is at 0.3%.
A bill de Blasio is up to 0.7% from I think
like 0.5.
I mean, this is basically all zero.
So in total Williamson Inslee, Deblazio, Delaney
Bennet Castro, Ryan Bullock Club, a Char Seth
Moulton who wasn't even in the debates and
Kirsten Gillibrand all under 1%.
Um, and then you have Tulsi Gabbert and Andrew
Yang between one and 2%.
Now those two are interesting names.
Yang supporters were saying, hoping that Andrew
Yang would explode after his participation
in the first debate hasn't happened.
Admittedly, he didn't get much of a chance
to talk, uh, Tulsi Gabard supporters loudly
saying before the debate that she was going
to explode as soon as the country became more
aware of her.
Her polling hasn't moved at all either.
Uh, and it's interesting to note that there
was a lot of bragging after the debates from
supporters of some of these lower polling
candidates saying x was the most searched
for candidate on Google.
Right after the debate, they're going to explode
in the polls.
And what I was saying at the time, and, and
clearly is, is true is that just because a
lot of people are googling someone's name
doesn't mean they're impressed with them or
plan to vote for them.
For example, Marianne Williamson was saying
wacky things and no one knew who she was.
So it makes sense that a lot of people would
start searching her name on Google to figure
out who she is, not necessarily to vote for
her.
And the polling seems to bear that out.
A Tulsi Gabbert I hate to break it to people.
Um, but she, a lot of the, the, uh, searches
for Tulsi Gabard were because she did make
Tim Ryan look really stupid on that issue
of the Taliban.
Also, if you looked at a lot of the comments
online, it clearly appears that there are
lots of men who are quite taken and women
potentially quite taken with an attractive
30 something year old candidate and they didn't
know who she was, so they were googling her
name.
It is not translating into polling growth,
at least not in the three post debate polls
so far.
Andrew Yang, again, lots of searches for Andrew
Yang picked up a lot of Twitter followers.
Doesn't mean that this is someone who's a
Google searches are necessarily going to translate
into polling support.
So the question now starts to become how long
are some of these zeros and ones going to
stay in?
Um, for those who were in the debate, they
don't seem to have gained polling support
and that's something they're going to have
to think about the the Zeros and ones who
didn't even make the debates, which are Seth
Moulton and there might be one or two others.
It's just time for them to go.
I mean they never had a chance to begin with
and they should go on the show tomorrow.
I'm going to address a question that our audience
is very divided about.
The question is, when does this polling matter
in the sense of historically, when do polling
numbers start to reflect who is likely to
actually secure nominations?
The answer is, it's right around now, but
I'm going to go into detail about that on
tomorrow's program.
Lastly, there are people who are emailing
me saying, David, you should not be looking
at national polls.
You should be looking at the Iowa caucus polls
because that's the first caucus.
I believe it's in January, February.
Uh, and that's going to set the tone for how
the entire primary goes.
Yeah, I mean, it's fine to do that.
It's not actually that interesting yet because
right now there's this 15% cutoff in the Iowa
caucuses.
If you don't get 15% support, you don't get
any delegates from the Iowa caucus right now.
It would just be Biden and Sanders who get,
uh, any delegates from Iowa.
And that's the way it's been for awhile.
So in fact, that hasn't really changed.
No one else has polling at 15% in Iowa, although
I believe Pete Budaj edge is close, maybe
at 12% just shy of the 15% requirement.
So yeah, you will start looking at Iowa when
it's actually closer.
Right now the national polls actually do tell
us a quite a bit.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I've been open to having my mind changed about
this for months, but so far it's been more
or less, uh, as our analysis has predicted.